[Music]
mickey you're a wine lover
i love wine you love wine yes you
love you're probably gonna say no but
i'm still gonna ask do you love taco
bell
i love taco bell oh yeah nice [ __ ] yeah
well your dream has come true because
they're one in taco bell
what the bells coming out with their own
wine finally jalapeno noir
yes i didn't know they had a liquor
license is this a joke is it all over
why do they put garlic in the wine
garlic
oh i think it's the light reflection if
they do it if they do a drive-through
we're officially in idiocracy
yeah i'm into that too i'm down i just
watched that movie on the plane to vegas
they hand you a glass
it was a really good movie because it
just reminded me of like
it's like today yeah i just recently saw
it because we talked about it on the
show and i was like you gotta watch this
movie it's always being
uh referenced then yeah isn't it funny
how that was a comedy back then and
they're like that'll never happen and
it's like oh
[ __ ] that's now so good especially the
opening part where
the couple that like went to college and
stuff and they became doctors they're
like we're waiting to have children yeah
and then they can't get they can't get
pregnant and
now all the idiots breed anyway back to
this
so taco bell is actually partnering up
with a winery in
canada because this is going to be
canada
in canada oh it's only in canada only in
canada
why would they need tacos so they're
saying well
like maybe to them that's real tacos but
what vineyards can grow
out there i guess i'm very ignorant to
the landscape ontario
okay okay in ontario there's they have a
vineyard
and so right now taco bell is there in
an update
wouldn't they be frozen grapes and
frozen jewels are good too
yeah there's like wine slushy you know
frozen grapes actually produce really
good wine we were in germany and there's
this vineyard and they harvest them
right when they freeze but have you ever
put grapes in the freezer though and ate
it like a snack like that
dude my mom does that and she's like i'm
having a healthy snack and then like 20
minutes later because she had sweets
she's
eating chocolate it cancels it yeah it
just opened pandora's box yeah but yeah
so taco bell
they are coming out with a new chalupa
called the toasted
cheesy chalupa oh my gosh and so how do
they make things better i love you taco
bell
so they're saying that wine and cheese
is a beautiful pairing
that kind of cheese they're gonna be
complimenting real cheese taco bell
yeah or or dairy free nikki's even got
the colors for taco bell going on and
stuff oh yeah
i do that's the only fast food place i
actually like
will drive through and order stuff like
you all you actually get dressed up for
my outfit you're like moving your hair
like it's the only place i get dressed
up for is talk about driving trying to
flirt
you know they give out taco bell rings
to some people like if they really like
them yeah
i'm trying to get me one yeah talk about
what does that look like
oh like influencers i've seen them send
like taco bell rings
dude the real influencers get invited to
[ __ ] taco bell thanksgiving
friendsgiving what is that i don't know
i never got invited yeah we see tim go
every year
yeah dude i was like right in that group
and then
just got completely overlooked tim's in
every [ __ ] grease and drake's group
and [ __ ] justin bieber's group he
socializes though that's true jim was
like in [ __ ] mcgregor's corner during
the fight was he
no that would be great i wouldn't i
wouldn't even be surprised if i'd be
like i wouldn't be surprised
[ __ ] tim's everywhere so back to this
so then they're saying
that the wine in case you're interested
because you love wine
is that it has notes of wild strawberry
cherry and beetroot in a silky
red wine so it sounds like a pinot noir
or wait what is it yes is that a dessert
wine it's a red wine huh
no it's not it's not oh so it's not
sweet where's the jalapeno part
they didn't mention it maybe they were
just trying to make a play on words
because like pinot
noir jalapeno noir but i expect
jalapenos in there they can't [ __ ] with
me
too like i kind of wish they had like a
hint of spice a little i need that
good yeah you definitely need it i used
to like taco bell to until they
um once they changed i was like y'all
ain't trashy changed what like the
outside
everything yeah they got kind of bougie
the branding the flavors
everything changed i would like to call
something out about talking about right
now they're getting rid of they're
getting rid of the [ __ ] mexican pizza
no way i always order that i swear to
god wow they're actually getting rid of
quite a few things from the menu to make
room for new stuff i always
order that it's a staple we're getting
rid of mexican pizza
pico de gallo and shredded chicken so
any dishes that have shredded chicken in
it
we should have told everyone to sit down
before we told them this news this is
the mexican pizza though that's
[ __ ] up that's like a staple yeah i
literally always order it they're also
getting rid of the seven layer burritos
yeah
nachos i tried to order it nacho supreme
wait why nacho supreme that's a staple
yeah and the beefy fritos burrito which
i personally [ __ ] love when we
always order that that's just an attack
on poor people that one when we jump to
vegas
because i only get one thing i talk
about the seven layer burrito and then i
make all these modifications to it
um i was like i want the seven layer
burrito but no no cheese no
like frustrating no meat nothing yeah no
layers
just the lettuce and portuguese i think
that they don't i don't know if this is
true for all of their dishes
but i do know that they're adding um
that they have a lot more vegan options
yeah so i think they're not using real
cheese so you just say fresco style
usually and they take out the meat and
cheese
but the guy was like we don't have seven
layer burritos anymore i was like okay
then just give me a burrito that has
beans rice
lettuce tomato and he's like well what
burrito do you want
and i was like i don't [ __ ] know
because i usually get the seven layer
burritos cause what he's saying is
what button do you want me to punch
no button i was like it's idiocracy
hey stupid there's no they don't have
that
yeah can i put the lettuce in a cup and
call it a drink
he's a savage on this guy look if he's
watching this he's like there is no
button
that's true have you seen those uh
mcdonald's
he was high as [ __ ] when i picked up the
foot
the name of the [ __ ] were pictures no
yeah they they were not even named in
the 90s when i saw the little board i
wanted to be a mcdonald's worker because
they
just pressed the pictures they gives you
condition
for that oh like oh it's so cool it's
your job you just because they press
pictures
no but um in in their place though they
are mentioning that they will be coming
out with
a tropical ice drink called the dragon
fruit freeze
and the chicken chipotle melt below me
with the freezes just keep the mexican
pizza yeah they're trying to get really
classy that's why i was like
i don't like i didn't like taco i like
the old logo
that was yellow and green and it had
that doo doo brown
with a bell fat bell yes the big bad del
taco came in and took the colors
well del taco was orange and oh my gosh
yellow orange and yellow and yellow and
then i i used to love taco bell
when it used to when it was more humble
yeah when it was very 90s i love that
90s like confetti
thing that they would put on the logo oh
yeah yeah like like it's like
surprise taco bell but they were kind of
similar if you remember the tacos it was
just a dry ass shell
with good old-fashioned mystery meat
lettuce
you know and then that's why i love del
taco because it's got that same
feel to it and then now taco bell's just
kind of like
it's like oh you're you think you're
better than us you're going down though
in high school we had the ten dollar
challenge did you ever have that
where you it was almost impossible to
eat ten dollars worth of taco bell food
because you get so much [ __ ] food
yeah dude now if you customize one
burrito it's ten dollars yeah exactly
that's true i'm starting to see the
light on your del taco thing yeah i
can't the fact that they sell those
fries i just can't do it
i like the fries sprinkle fries that's
fried and now they got like conasatta
fries
i'm not saying the fries aren't good i'm
just saying the fact that they're
they're partnering it up i just can't
[ __ ] with it oh that's like cafeteria
food though
so like when i look at del taco i was
actually angry when they try to be more
mexican
because i was like why you have carne
asada now like you're not
that like you know you're like the white
guy that hangs out with a bunch of
mexicans like you're not
you're not full mexican like you gotta
you gotta give me
what i was born with like the fake [ __ ]
like taco night kind of food that's that
ground beef seasoned
oh yeah steve just made that uh two
nights yeah
dude he's the white guy making tacos
jack in the box knows what they're doing
though jack in the box is like hey we
know it's stoner food dude come get it
five dollar box curly fries on a melted
grilled cheese we don't know you're
stoned yeah
they have cheesecake and egg rolls like
[ __ ] kids oh yeah exactly dude they
know exactly who their customer base is
and it's pretty good yeah and everything
the oil is
the oil goes through every bag which is
awesome transparent food that's how you
know it's jack-in-the-box
yeah when their fries are just soaked in
cream
no when your bag breaks open all over
the stairs you're like jacking up
the back of the box but you're so high
you're just like
[ __ ] it you try to rescue it whatever
you can get up that's why you spent ten
dollars
that's always gonna make it inside they
got those crisscross fries right
oh yeah no that's crazy
damn y'all eat a lot of fast food jax
has the swirly fries yeah jack's has
curly fries i like
those too you're like old fries potato
wedges thingy with the ripples
don't they have i think they have
ripples i don't think so i think
we always had a jack-in-the-box like
pretty close by and i wanted to try it
and my parents would refuse to let me go
because do you remember it almost went
like out of business yeah yeah
oh before they brought the jack the jack
head right right my parents like yeah
you get mad cow disease or something
yeah someone goes
in the box was about to go someone got
sick a lot of them were
when i was a child yeah like a lot of
them were gone
there was only a few there and then it
made a comeback
and then jack was the character and all
that well he was
an old character they used to use they
they took him out and then it started
going under they brought them back
that was what saved them he's hilarious
i love those commercials you know why i
miss though the moon guy from mcdonald's
me too that's my guy right there which
one's the moon guy
there's a big old channel tonight max
tonight
mack tonight i have all the toys they in
the like little cars you had a tux
i missed the upside down purple tree
what upside down oh they're like
purple is it grimace the purple guy from
mcdonald's yeah grimace is hilarious
i get them confused with the chocolate
cheese yeah i'm just gonna say does the
chucky cheese have the same
but i gotta say the burger king mascot's
the best one of all time the king
the creepy one yeah keep recreating
where he's like outside of people's
windows and he's like
yeah the commercials are pretty funny
what about hamburglar you don't like
hamburger hamburger's great he's great
he's classic
what do you think about jack-in-the-box
updating their logo in science because
it used to be super simple like
jack and they had the b and the o x that
looked like a fish
the o and the x it made like a fish i
forgot i'll just remember those now it's
like all cursive
yeah it's all fancy i just remember a
box like a red box yeah yeah yeah and
then oh that was original right yeah
red box and now it's all fancy yeah oh
yeah i don't know i haven't been there
in a minute
but they were um i don't have like
childhood memories because i didn't eat
there yeah my childhood memory of taco
bello is the chihuahua
me too oh yeah okay taco bell
you know the guy that voiced that oh
yeah that's right yeah was he mexican
i mean like i know i'm like acquaintance
wise but i'm like dude every time i
speak to him i'll be like please please
do it
do it again
[Applause]
[Music]
you